Nos dicen que: "Clara toma una rebanada de pizza
del congelador y la deja en la barra de la cocina
mientras se descongela. Ella modela la relación
entre la temperatura P de la pizza (en grados
Celsius) y el tiempo T desde que la sacó del
congelador (en minutos), donde P = 20 - 25 • 0.8
a la T. Clara quiere graficar la relación durante
los primeros 25 minutos". Entonces, lo que vamos
a hacer aquí no es enfocarnos en la gráfica misma,
aunque la veremos, aquí voy a usar una calculadora
gráfica para tener acceso a ella, pero quiero que
veamos la gráfica en el contexto de lo que estamos
tratando de modelar y pensar cuidadosamente en
cuáles deberían ser las etiquetas de los ejes,
qué partes de las gráficas nos interesan. Muy
bien, aquí está esta función graficada en Desmos.
Puedes ver que lo escribí justo aquí: P = 20 - 25
• 0.8 a la potencia T, exactamente lo que teníamos
aquí abajo. Ahora, recuerda: esto está modelando
la temperatura de nuestra pizza como función del
tiempo. Entonces para ayudarnos a recordar eso
pongamos algunas etiquetas en nuestros ejes,
configuremos la gráfica: si bajo aquí nuestro
eje X es realmente el eje T, es nuestra variable
independiente que está aquí, y ¿qué está midiendo?
Bueno, lo dice por aquí: mide el tiempo T en minutos,
entonces lo escribimos así: T que se mide en
minutos, y luego ¿qué pasa con nuestro eje Y?
Bueno, este es realmente nuestro eje P, y mide
grados Celsius, es nuestro eje P y mide grados
Celsius. Muy bien, veamos cómo luce la gráfica
hasta ahora. Ahí la tenemos, hemos etiquetado
nuestros ejes y ya hemos escrito esta parte, ahora
podemos enfocarnos en la gráfica en sí. Ahora,
¿hemos terminado?, ¿esto es en todo lo que debemos
pensar? Bueno, la siguiente parte en la que
debemos pensar es el dominio, ¿cuál es el rango
que nos interesa? Bueno, lo primero que debemos
darnos cuenta es que estamos modelando algo como
función del tiempo, por lo que no deberíamos
tener tiempo negativo aquí; queremos pensar en
la relación durante los primeros 25 minutos,
así que volvamos a la configuración. Y cuando
vemos el rango de valores de X que nos importa,
que es la parte del dominio que nos interesa,
queremos restringir a X como mayor o igual a
0. Aquí X es realmente T y también nos interesa
que sea menor a 25, no tenemos que restringir el
límite superior pero son los primeros 25 minutos
los que nos interesan, así que hagámoslo así.
Ahora veamos nuestra gráfica. Es importante tener
en cuenta que tenemos los ejes, podemos verlos,
cuando T = 0 vemos que tenemos una temperatura
negativa en grados Celsius, y eso tiene sentido,
la rebanada de pizza salió del congelador, por
lo que su temperatura está bajo 0, y luego vemos
que la pizza se está calentando cada vez más
conforme se acerca a la temperatura ambiente,
que aquí parece estar bastante cerca de 20
grados Celsius. Y, ahora, parece que hemos podido
graficar lo que Clara está tratando de observar,
parece que lo hemos modelado bien, lo
hemos etiquetado en consecuencia y hemos
establecido los rangos de valores X y los
rangos de los valores Y que queremos ver. Para
los valores de Y sólo queremos asegurarnos de
que correspondan al rango de valores de X, que
es realmente un subconjunto del dominio para
no confundirnos demasiado con el término rango,
el subconjunto del dominio de los valores x que
nos interesan, y de los cuales podemos ver los
valores correspondientes en Y, sin duda podemos
verlos. Y esencialmente hemos terminado, hemos
pensado en la mejor forma de graficar este modelo.